hey guys we're already in the middle of
January and even though you might think
it's a dry season there are a lot of
games coming out this week so let's get
into it first up is Resident Evil 0 HD
remaster along with better visuals
Resident Evil 0 HD has improved sound
widescreen support and the option to use
a modernized control setup in terms of
story Resident Evil 0 is set for the
events of the original resident evil
which Capcom also recently remade you
probably remember Rebecca chambers and
Billy Cohen right well the duo works
together to survive a virus that is
resulted in a zombie outbreak but if you
want HD remasters of Resident Evil 0 as
well as Resident Evil you can pick up
the origins collection that's available
on xbox one ps4 and PC on the 19th
darkest dungeon is a super difficult
roguelike dungeon crawler made by a
bunch of jerks that like watching the
player lose you manage a roster of
heroes that are ready to explore
dungeons below a gothic mansion you just
inherited but pretty much everything
down there kills you and the people in
your party gets scared and lose their
sanity and then they just start missing
shots or freak out all together and try
to leave you i played this with alexa
when it was an early access it was
depressingly enjoyable take from that
what you will this also comes out on the
19th moving on to blade and soul you
might recall it was hugely successful in
Asia when it first launched in 2013
reportedly hitting 1.8 million
concurrent users within the year in
China alone to give it some perspective
blizzards world warcraft hit 1 million
subscribers in North America and Canada
after a year launched at launch the game
will feature seven classes 30 dungeons a
level cap of 45 and a 1v1 arena it was
popular there might be popular here and
that comes to PC on the 19th
moving on to some couch combat there's
move or die a fast pace for player local
online party game where the mechanics
change every 20 seconds now there's a
lot of couch combat games coming out all
the time but this one had a really good
trailer so I'm interested but if you're
more of a retro-inspired person there's
Stardust Vanguard that has military
leaders equipping themselves with giant
mech robots armed with only an energy
sword and an auto targeting machine gun
space fight take your pick or if you
like couch combat get them both make
them fight to the death next up ps4
owners get Klaus a 2d puzzle platformer
players will be able to move and rotate
objects like jump pads platforms spikes
and other stuff by using unique touch
features at both ps4 and Vita I don't
know too much about this game story
looks pretty intriguing kind of got that
weird moment ova and if you're intrigued
you can pick it up on the 19th moving on
to 3ds owners in North America you get
Mario and Luigi paper jam while
attempting to fix a hole in Princess
Peach's castle library Luigi
accidentally trips and knocks over a
mysterious book containing the paper
mario world causing the paper-thin
residence within it to spread across the
Mushroom Kingdom gameplay looks like it
has some interesting mechanics but more
importantly I want to know who the
author of that book is this is out on
the 22nd
also this week Atlas gifts us with the
deadly Tower of monsters follow some
movie stars clearly playing some b level
sci-fi characters you get dick star
speed scarlet Nova and robot in this
really silly sci-fi adventure all set to
ridiculous self-aware director
commentary also on the 19th finally
you're invited to lead the expedition
that started it all in homeworld deserts
of Kharak it's a ground-based sci-fi RTS
from Blackbird interactive a studio
founded by veterans of the homeworld and
company of heroes franchises good
pedigree you get to take control of
fleets of land and air vehicles to
conquer massive sand dunes in the desert
your choices in resource management
fleet composition and technology
research will impact your chances of
survival good luck to you on the 20th so
between the resident evil remasters the
new homeworld and the soul-crushing
darkest dungeon there's actually a lot
of games coming out this week let me
know what you're interested in picking
up remember that release dates are based
on retailer listings and sometimes they
change I'll see you next week